-Thank you and welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah, you're here.
[ Whistling ]
Thank you very much.
Well, guys, as much
as we'd like to move on,
former President Trump
is still in the news.
We thought we drove him
to a farm upstate,
but he somehow found his way
back home to the headlines.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, last night,
House impeachment managers
delivered the impeachment
article against Trump
to the Senate.
If you missed it,
here they are walking it over.
[ Camera shutters
clicking continuously ]
[ Laughter ]
Okay, alright, okay, yeah, okay.
After 45 minutes,
they were like,
"Wait, does anyone know
where we're going?"
It's like, "No.
I'm following you.
I thought you --"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah, it turns out half of them
were delivering the articles.
The other half were just
getting in their steps.
[ Laughter ]
I say forget impeachment.
Just having Trump make that walk
would be punishment enough.
[ Laughter ]
It looked like a wedding,
when the deejay says,
"Table 6,
you can go to the salad bar."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the walk was pretty long
and drawn out.
It kind of reminded me
of something, though.
[ George Baker Selection's
"Little Green Bag" plays ]
♪♪
♪ Yeah ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-♪ Lookin' for some happiness ♪
♪ But there is only loneliness ♪
♪ To find ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Whistling ]
-I knew it.
[ Laughter ]
Well, speaking
of the former president,
sources in touch with Trump
have said he's...
[ Laughter ]
Well, he was already
out of his mind,
so I guess, now,
he's just bored.
[ Laughter ]
Apparently, playing 36 holes
of golf every day
isn't as exciting when you're
not ignoring a global pandemic.
[ Laughter ]
But today, Trump's aides
were trying to cheer him up.
They were like,
"Good news, sir.
Your trial starts in two weeks."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile,
President Biden's very busy
and, today, he spoke
with Vladimir Putin
for the first time
since taking office.
As soon as the call began,
Trump was like --
[ As Trump ]
I feel a disturbance
in the force.
[ Laughter ]
But this is good --
Biden actually pressed Putin
on last year's massive
Russian cyber attack.
Putin denied it, but it got
weird when he was like --
[ As Putin ]
By the way, nice purple tie.
He's like, "Wait.
We're not on Zoom.
How did you know that was...?"
[ Laughter ]
I think you can tell Putin
was used to talking to Trump
because, out of habit,
he ended the call with --
[ As Putin ]
Love you, too.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Some tech news --
I saw that Apple has issued
a new warning to customers.
Listen to this.
-An important health warning
for all iPhone users.
Apple warns customers that
the smartphones could interfere
with medical devices,
most notably, pacemakers.
This is bad news
for all the grandmothers
who like to connect
their iPhone to a chest mount
when they do base jumping.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
It'll be weird when a guy
is like, "I love this phone.
Hey, Siri,
turn off my pacemaker."
[ Laughter ]
And get this -- I saw
that Tyson Foods is releasing
heart-shaped chicken nuggets
for Valentine's Day.
Or, as I always say,
if you want to keep it classy,
go with the standard scratch-off
ticket and beef jerky.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, that makes
an edible arrangement
look like a diamond necklace.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, you can sprinkle
the nuggets on your bed
and then uncover her eyes
and watch her as she says,
"I'm going to stay
at my sister's."
[ Laughter and applause ]
But they're on your side
of the bed, honey!
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
I could hold you up by your legs
and you could just eat them off
like a --
[ Laughter ]
like a nugget stand,
like a keg stand, but like a --
Like an anteater.
[ Laughter ]
Look, I won't judge, but if your
Valentine's Day plan involves
the words dipping sauces,
you might want
to rethink things.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of food,
Panera has created
a new Red Bull glove
for customers.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Clapping ]
-Yes!
-For customers who drink
iced coffee in the winter.
Look at that thing again.
Look at that.
[ Laughter ]
Actually, I think the gloves
are going to be a huge hit.
Check out who I saw
wearing them today.
There you go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
He had a double loaf.
Have you guys seen
the slow Zoom interviews
that Vanity Fair does?
They ask celebrities
personal questions
and a camera very slowly
gets closer to their face.
They've done it
with RuPaul, Tyra Banks.
They just did one
with Billie Eilish.
And I actually
did one, too, but,
they had me do
a fast Zoom, instead.
Here, take a look.
-Fast Zoom interview
with Jimmy Fallon.
Take 1.
[ Clack ]
-What's your favorite
brand of toothpaste?
-Um, gosh.
[ Laughter ]
Crest?
[ Beep, clack ]
-What's your favorite
late night snack?
-Probably, uh --
it's probably frozen pizza,
probably frozen pizza.
[ Laughter ]
-What's your favorite
ice cream flavor?
-I like mint chocolate chip.
-What kind of sandwiches
do you like?
-Hey, get -- This is how
the interview goes?
[ Laughter ]
[ Beep, clack ]
Hey, is my publicist here?
[ Laughter ]
Is this --
No, no, I don't want to do --
[ Laughter ]
[ Bleep ]
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
-How many slices will you eat,
if you're left
to your own devices?
[ Laughter ]
-I'd eat like two slices
of pizza.
-Great interview.
Thank you so much.
[ Laughter, whistling,
and applause ]
-And, finally, a 12-year-old
in Canada set a new world record
when he stacked 693 Jenga blocks
on top of a single vertical
Jenga block.
Here's a photo.
Look at this.
-Oh!
-What?!
-That doesn't look like Jenga.
That looks like
a wooden shawarma spit.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. The Jenga stack was cool,
until his little brother
walked by and just went --
[ Blows sharply ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Whistling ]
Thank you so much for watching.
We have a big show tonight.
She's a guest star
on Season 4
of "Search Party" on HBO Max.
Susan Sarandon is here!
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
Plus, we're going to talk
about his charity,
the JJ Watt Foundation.
From the Houston Texans,
JJ Watt is here!
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
And tonight is the night
we have a performance
from Thad Cockrell, everybody.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
And we're very excited
about this.
This is -- Oh, look at this.
Pink vinyl.
[ Audience murmuring ]
"Ooh la la, Sasson."
This is the song that I heard
in a hardware store
in quarantine, my first trip
out in quarantine.
I went to the hardware store
and I heard the song
and it sounded like
a George Harrison type of vibe
or something to it.
And I just Shazam'd it
and I go, "What is this?"
Swingin'.
If we're going to go down,
we're going to go down swinging.
It is so good.
♪ 'Cause if we go ♪
Let me just play a little
because you're going to --
Already, just crank up
your TVs already.
Say about one 130,
get in there, 120?
♪♪
Oh, no, no.
Earlier.
-♪ End that way ♪
-Here we go.
-♪ Just stay ♪
-Here we go. 1, 2, 3.
-♪ If I'm gonna go down ♪
♪ I wanna go down swingin' ♪
♪ I wanna go down hard ♪
-I mean, dude, he hit the notes
and everything. I was like --
♪ Wah da dee ♪
And I was just doing that
in the hardware store.
[ Laughter ]
♪ I wanna go down ♪
I should've been
in the hammer section.
-Yeah.
-You know?
[ Laughter ]
But I wasn't.
I was in the --
I was in the screwdriver/
light switch section.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I don't really know
my way around.
-I was wondering what you were
doing in the hardware store.
[ Laughter ]
-What do you mean,
what I was doing
in the hardware store?
I'm doing what any
-You just needed --
-You needed someplace
-man of the house does.
-to drive your truck to, just --
[ Laughter ]
-Well, my driver
took the truck there and...
[ Laughter ]
...I said, "Pierre,
you're going a little fast,
[ Laughter ]
don't you think?"
-French driver.
-I said, "Slow down."
I have a French driver, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Slow down.
You're making me a little sick.
My caviar's about to come out."
[ Laughter ]
No, yeah, I took the truck.
You know, I do like,
you know, like --
you know, like you slide
into the window
to get in the truck.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. I go in through the roof,
the sunroof.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-Yeah.
I leave the sunroof open
and I hop into it
like Super Mario.
[ Laughter ]
-On a 4x4?
-It's a 4x4, yeah.
-Wow.
-I mean --
-That's impressive.
I don't know. 4x4? Sure.
[ Laughter ]
Four wheels.
4x4 -- like yeah.
-It's a hell of a jump.
You have an incredible
vertical, if you do that.
-It's a cube.
It's 4 foot by 4 feet truck.
-Oh.
-Oh, no.
I jump from the second floor.
[ Laughter ]
I jump out the bedroom window
and land in my truck.
And then, it's already gotten
onto a song
and I cruised out,
went to the hardware store
to get a light switch,
like this, like a lamp switch.
-Hm.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
That wasn't a "Hm."
That wasn't an interesting "Hm."
That was a "Hm" of doubt.
-Yeah.
It was a "Hm" of doubt.
No, I know what this is.
To put those clicker
light switches on this,
you only cut one of the wires,
not both of them.
You leave the other one
connected
and then, what it does is it
connects the, you know, the --
negative charge.
You want to keep.
[ Laughter ]
-Got it. Got it.
-You want to keep the positive.
-Really?
-You want to keep that positive
charge going, yeah.
-Want to accentuate
the positive.
-Make sure you unplug before you
even mess around
with this stuff, kids.
-Nice.
-Nothing metal in your hands
or anything.
-What's that?
-No electricity, no metal
in your hands.
-No. Don't.
Stay away from water,
any liquid, stuff like that.
Just your basic
electricity knowledge.
[ Laughter ]
And so I did that.
I was working. I was ready
to work on that like a project
and then my mind was blown.
I heard the song,
"Swingin'," by Thad Cockrell.
I go, "I never heard
Thad Cockrell,"
and then I looked him up.
I guess he's been around, so.
But, anyways,
I was feeling that spirit
of like,
because we were doing
the show from home,
which is just like,
everybody's trying
to get through the day
and it was like, "We just got
to put on the best thing
we can possibly do
with what we got, you know?
Don't give up.
Let's keep pushing. Let's go."
And I was feeling that spirit
and then I heard that song.
It spoke to me.
I loved it.
I asked our booker,
"Can we book him?"
And tonight he's on the show,
playing with The Roots tonight,
which is very exciting.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It's exciting.